interviewing everyone from Led
Zeppelin's Jimmy Page to NFL superstar
Tom Brady Chuck Klosterman span of work
is varied to say the least
Chuck is a best-selling author of eight
non-fiction books and two novels he's
also written for publications like the
New York Times and GQ his latest work
Chuck Klosterman ten a highly specific
defiantly incomplete history of the
early 21st century is a collection of
columns and articles published over the
past decade Chuck Klosterman good
morning welcome great to be here thanks
for having me on you cover a lot of
ground in here one of the the early
essays that you have in this book is
about zombies that you were commissioned
to write by the New York Times I think
and you say in a lot of modern life is
exactly exactly like slaughtering
zombies yeah well the conceit about that
was you know everybody now seems to have
an understanding of if there is a zombie
apocalypse how to deal with it so it's
widely understood you just like you take
a shotgun or some kind of axe and you
just keep kind of knocking them down as
they come at you over and over again and
as I was writing this I was like that's
sort of like dealing with email it's
reference well example because it you'll
never finish right you know they'll
never be a point where you're there'll
be no more emails to look at or no more
things to sort of check on so you live
your life sort of in a technology-based
world like you're destroying zombies
you're just in a corner trying to
survive by in a Nile aiding them one by
one it feels like the zombies actually
are more deadly than those emails might
be maybe I'm not certain in that
actually in the intro to that you also
wrote about getting the piece and sort
of it had you said you were a big fan of
the work they would have given it to you
had you said as you did that you weren't
they gave it to you and I thought that
in all these intros to your stories you
really did a great job of sort of
exploring something about each one did
you learn a lot about your stories and
looking back to put this together well I
suppose a little bit I mean you can only
learn so much about work you did
yourself right like you can't you can't
read something you wrote and then be
surprised by it um but what I just try
to do is don't I IRA publish these
pieces because they have run elsewhere
their people have seen them before
but you know everything is it's the
commedia is such a constructed reality
that I always think
interesting if you can tell people just
a little bit of how it actually is like
how these things actually come into
being and what the experience of meeting
these people is actually like because
the stories sometimes don't reflect that
yeah they sort of get changed by the way
by like the manufacturing process of
magazines or the internet or whatever
there's a number of great music stories
in the book and I was surprised to see
that you were a big fan of KISS you say
social the social footprint they leave
is deeper than their catalog yeah I mean
kiss is my favorite band to think about
okay well The Beatles are my favorite
band to listen to but this is my
favorite band to think about I think
that they are the most interesting band
in a way it's almost like you can
understand the entire concept and sort
of the unreality of rock music through
the trajectory of their career and you
know I was into kiss when I was young
and I never really stopped I think
what's really interesting about being
into kisses you can have almost an
adversarial relationship with the band
but it's not like Bruce Springsteen
right where you think to yourself oh boy
if you know when he's not on tour he's
probably working at a car wash in New
Jersey you know this lion is Asian with
kiss you can make fun of them while you
like them you also had a lot of sports
stories in here Tom Brady and Kobe
Bryant couldn't have been to more
different interviews for you either I
mean in practice absolutely I mean Kobe
Bryant I went assuming it was going to
be a real difficult thing and he wanted
to talk about his life in a way that was
so lucid and upfront I mean I've never
had an interview with the sports athlete
yeah I'm reading it you hear more than
you normally and it just immediately
happened it's not like I spent a month
with him like is like 80 minutes and he
told me more in like 80 minutes than
most people I have talked to you for two
years but Tom Brady was the complete
opposite the whole reason I was doing
that interview I thought was to ask him
these questions about deflategate and
that the whole thing was set up so that
he would sort of address these issues
that he'd never lead rest before but
that wasn't the case at all I mean maybe
somebody said he was gonna do that but
he didn't know that how do you confront
that situation when you're when you I
mean we've all sort
Bennett I'm curious how you confront
that when you when somebody puts up a
wall like that well the thing is is when
I realize that this just wasn't going to
happen and that the central thing that
we were supposed to be discussing was
not going to be part of the conversation
at all for a while I thought well maybe
this story will just be eliminated maybe
it'll just evaporate but it was for
gqueues Man of the Year issue and Tom
Brady was the man of the year but so
that's not good this story was going to
run even if he had never called me at
all so then I said well how about this
I'll write an essay about Tom Brady and
then in the middle I will include the
Q&A section of when I ask him these
questions no he refuses to answer but I
mean certainly there is something you
learn from someone when they say nothing
I mean the way that they react to
questions even if they're not giving you
information does maybe give you more
insight into what their personality is
really like as opposed to if they had a
constructed answer that they gave you
that is really no different than you
know public relations yeah Chuck we
appreciate the time thank you some great
stuff great work even you've seen it
before thank you